In the previous video, I introduced
a lot of new concepts that may or
may not be familiar to you.
To see all of these concepts in action,
in this section we're going to build our
own web server in Python that not only
renders web pages in a browser, but by
processing data submitted by the user,
can create a unique web page each
time a user modifies the input.
To get started let's create a new
Python file called webserver.py and
save it in the same directory
as your restaurantmenu.db.
And databasesetup.py files so we can
access it from our vagrant machine.
Follow along with me using Sublime or
your favorite text editor.
One of the cool things about Python is
that it comes with a large collection of
libraries we can use
right out of the box.
We will be using the HTTP base
server library extensively to
create this project.
Take a minute to skim over the HTTP
base server documentation on
the official Python
documentation website.
I will add from BaseHTTPServer
import BaseHTTPRequestHandler and
HTTPServer to the first line of my
webserver.py file to be able to
take advantage of this
BaseHTTPServer functionality.
Our web server code will have two
main sections, the main method and
the handler class.
In main we instantiate our server and
specify what port it will listen on.
Our handler code indicates what code
to execute based on the type of
HTTP request that is sent to the server.
I will start by coding a main method
as the entry point of my code.
I'll add this block of code at
the end of my file to immediately run
the main method when the Python
interpreter executes my script.
Inside this main method,
I will add a try except block.
The Python interpreter will try to
attempt the code inside the try block.
And if a defined event occurs, we can
exit out of the code with an exception.
The exception I want to
handle is KeyboardInterrupt.
This is a built-in exception in
Python that can be triggered when
the user holds Ctrl+C on the keyboard.
Going back inside my try block,
I will create an instance
of an HTTP server class.
Looking at the documentation for
HTTPServer, I see that I can
create a web server like so.
In the documentation we also see that
HTTPServer is built off of a TCPServer
class, indicating the transmission
protocol that this server will use.
Server address is a tuple that contains
the host and port number for our server.
I will leave host as an empty string and
specify our port number with an integer.
I will define port in
a separate variable, and
create my server instance as so.
Notice that I just made up a name,
webserverHandler, for
the request handler class.
I will define my webserverHandler
in the next section of code.
But first, let me add some
finishing code to the main method.
After I create the server I'll add
a print statement to know that my
server is running.
Then I will use this serve_forever
function built into my HTTPServer to
keep it constantly listening until I
call Ctrl+C or exit the application.
Inside my KeyboardInterrupt exception
I will shut down the server by
calling server.socket.close.
And I have another print statement,
just letting me know that
the server was properly stopped.
Above my main method,
I will now define the webserverHandler
class that I called in my HTTPServer,
and have it extend from a class
called BaseHTTPRequestHandler.
The do_GET function handles all get
requests our web server receives.
In order to figure out which resource
we are trying to access, we will use
a simple pattern matching plan that only
looks for the ending of our URL path.
Let's create another try except
block for our do_GET method.
The BaseHTTPRequestHandler
provides us a variable called path
that contains the URL sent by
the client to the server as a string.
I will make an if statement that looks
for the URL that ends with /hello.
I will tell my web server
to send a response code of
200 indicating a successful get request.
I will use the send_header function to
indicate that I'm replying with text in
the form of HTML to my client along
with this end_headers command which just
sends a blank line indicating the end
of our HTTP headers in the response.
Now that I've created the response
I can include some content to
send back to the client.
I'll create an empty string for
now and name it output.
In the next line I will add
a message with some HTML and
body tags to my output stream.
I can use the self.wfile.write function
to send a message back to the client.
So I'll go ahead and
put my output string there.
I'm going to add a print statement for
now, just so I can see my
output string in the terminal.
This might come in handy for debugging.
Then I can exit my if statement
with the return command.
I will also write an exception for
IOErrors, and
use the following line of code to notify
me of a 404 or file not found error.
Now, I think I'm ready to test and
see what I've written
thus far in the browser.